aquí tenemos la suma menos 50 más menos
44 más menos 38 y seguimos sumando hasta
tener 2 mil 38 más 2 mil 44 los invito a
que pausa en el vídeo y traten de
evaluar esta suma vamos a resolverlo
juntos y tratemos de ver de qué se trata
el primer término es menos 50 y luego
tenemos menos 44 así que el segundo
término es menos 50 más 6 para el tercer
término volvemos a sumar 6 menos 40 y 46
nos da menos 38 continuamos haciendo
esto seguimos sumando 6 hasta que
llegamos a 2.038 y para obtener el
último término le agregamos 6 a 2.038
para tener 2 mil 44 cada término
sucesivo tiene 6 más que el anterior así
que lo que tenemos aquí esta suma es una
serie aritmética es la suma de una
secuencia aritmética cada término va a
tener seis más o una cantidad constante
más comparada con el término anterior
como trabajar con series de sumas
aritméticas sabemos que si tomamos la
suma de los primeros n términos de una
secuencia aritmética o si estamos
evaluando los primeros n términos de una
serie aritmética va a ser igual al
primer término más el último término
entre 2 esto es el promedio entre el
primer y último término por n el número
de términos que nos interesan conocemos
este término de aquí que es a 1 y
también conocemos este término de acá
que es a en nuestro último término 2044
así que la pregunta es cuánto vale m con
cuántos términos estamos trabajando aquí
para pensar en ello tenemos que
encontrar cuántas veces estamos
agregando 6 cada vez para llegar desde
menos 50 hasta 2044 o lo que es lo mismo
2 mil 44 menos menos 50 que es lo mismo
que tener 2 mil 44 más 50 y esto va a
ser igual
2.094 y la razón por la que he hecho
esto es porque quiero saber cuánto he
recorrido o cuánta distancia hay entre
menos 50 y 2.044 tengo que agregar 50
para llegar a 0 desde menos 50 y a
partir de cero tengo que agregar 2 mil
44 para llegar a 2.044 así que son 50
para llegar a 0 más 2 mil 44 para llegar
a 2 mil 44 así que la cantidad es 2.094
sí estoy agregando 6 a cada término
cuántas veces tengo que sumar 6 para
llegar a 2 mil 94 pues para encontrar
esto vamos a dividir 2.094 entre 6
ponemos 36 por 3 18 20 menos 18 nos da 2
bajamos el 9 aquí ponemos 4 6 por 4 24
29 menos 24 es 5 bajamos el 4
6 cabe en el 54 9 veces 9 por 6 54 54 54
va a ser igual a cero así que para pasar
de menos 50 y llegar a 2.044 tuve que
sumar 6 349 veces aquí la asume una vez
aquí dos veces y aquí son trescientos
cuarenta y nueve veces que es une el
seis cuantos términos tengo quizás se
vean tentados a decir que tengo 349
términos pero en realidad tenemos 349
más un términos ya que son 349 las veces
que tuve que agregar un 6 pero comencé
con el menos 50 y aún no contamos este
primer término así que tenemos el primer
término más trescientos cuarenta y nueve
veces que sumamos el seis así que
tenemos 350 términos en esta suma así
que en este caso n es igual a 350 así
que podemos decir que la suma de los
primeros 350 términos es la suma del
primer término y el último término
entre 2 por 350 así que menos 50 más 2
mil 44 nos va a dar 1994 por 350 y 350
entre dos es 175 y esto va a ser igual
usamos nuestra calculadora para poner
1994 por 175 que nos da 300 48.950 lo
escribimos 348 1950 y podemos expresar
esto connotación sigma ahora que ya
conocemos el valor de m encontramos
nuestra respuesta esto es lo que
estábamos buscando pero si tienen
curiosidad podemos escribir esto como la
suma desde acá igual a 1 hasta acá igual
a 350
menos 50 más 6 x menos 1 recordemos que
no queremos agregar el primer término a
esta multiplicación por 6 para el último
término vamos a multiplicar este 6 349
veces y así expresamos esta serie
aritmética con notación sigma espero que
esto les haya sido de utilidad